Speaker 1: I want to address one of the
other stories that now is going to be
a really big story in the wake of
this leaked Supreme Court decision
that will, as far as we know, overturn Roe v Wade.
There immediately were gatherings of protesters
both on the pro-choice and anti-choice side at
the Supreme Court and elsewhere, as we just saw.
Protesters on both sides have been mostly
peaceful. And anecdotally, we have seen instances
of individuals allegedly escalating. There
have been some little brawls between the
two camps and police have gotten involved.
At this point, I can't say more than that,
but there is definitely the potential that we
will see continued or growing unrest surrounding
this decision. And the unrest may come from any
side. I condemn violence. I'm against violence.
Now that we've gotten that out of the way,
the right is acting as though it is the
pro-choice left that is uniquely and particularly
violent physically in this political disagreement.
And that is a lie. The history of anti abortion by
violence is abhorrent, and you can easily Google
this and find endless examples. CNN has one good
article about this. There have been more than 200
bombings and arson attacks at facilities that
offer abortion services. You could argue that
that's terrorism. It's meant to terrorize as
a group those who have or might someday seek
abortion services. The first reported clinic,
arson, was in 76, just after Roe v Wade. Wow.
What a shocker. There were clinic bombings in 78
and 84. In the nineties, it escalated even more.
Dr. David Gunn was shot and killed in Pensacola,
Florida, by a gunman against abortion.
Dr. John Bayard Britton and his security
escort were shot and killed in front of a
Pensacola clinic. Clinic employees Shannon loud
it. Now, Clowney and Leon Nichols were shot and
killed in Brookline, Massachusetts. Off duty
police officer Robert Sanderson was killed
in the bombing of a Birmingham, Alabama clinic.
A sniper killed Dr. Barnett Slepian in Amherst,
New York, and famously, famously an anti-abortion
gunman killed 67 year old George Tiller
in Wichita, Kansas, in 2009. That's a story
we covered at the time. Our show was on the
air. He was he was killed. He was an abortion
clinic director. So these are extraordinarily
violent folks who have been willing to do all
sorts of violence. You could argue it's also
violence to show up and intimidate people going
in for medical services as they've done all over
the country. And yet you have all of these people
on the right acting as though the right that is
against abortion is completely peaceful. There is
one tweet here from who is this from? This is from
Rebecca mansour, who's the senior editor
of Breitbart News who said, quote,
The freakout you are witnessing from the left
is very instructive. When Roe was handed down
49 years ago, pro-lifers didn't riot, didn't call
for the Supreme Court to be burned down, didn't
threaten the lives of justices and didn't try to
stack the court. Well, they did 200 bombings in
attacks of abortion clinics. Then Jill Filipovic,
who's a writer, law lawyer and author, tweeted,
Actually, since Roe was handed down 49 years ago,
so-called pro-lifers have committed 11 murders.
26 attempted murders, four kidnapings 42 bombings,
667 bomb threats, 100 butyric acid attacks,
189 arsons on and on and on. They are violent.
They are violent. Don't let them trick you
into thinking that it is the pro-choice left
that is the violent group now. Could either
could individuals on either side anecdotally
commit violence in the next few days? Sure.
And I'm against it. And they should be arrested
if they commit a crime or are believed to have
committed a crime and they should be charged
and prosecuted. Absolutely. Both sides don't
care who it is, but the historical record is
the violence comes from the anti-choice side.
We'll have these clips and tweets on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman show